Julianna she’s just fabulous to
work with.
We have so much fun together.
It can be very daunting going on
to another show
that’s not yours, that’s already
been established.
But I knew Jen because we had
worked together and
come up together so she
was a very welcome
sight for me.
She was on E.R. and I was on
Friends, and our stage is
just like a stone’s throw away.
We used to go out and we’d
chat with each other.
What was the nature of your
relationship with Mitch Kessler?
Seeing Laura go toe to toe with
Alex Levy is really fun because
these are women
who have history.
She’s very seasoned.
Sophie and I, our costume
designer, talked about
making her look a little bit
like Katherine Hepburn
with the turtleneck and the
white shirt.
It was important to really
define her the very first time
we meet her on camera
and I needed her to have
a sense of authority
and feel distinctly different
from the other women
on the show.
Well if it isn’t Bradley Jackson
Yup that’s me. I’ve heard so
much about you.
Bradley is such an infinitely
curious person
That she’s always pushing to
discover more about herself, so
It felt so in character for
Bradley to be
exploring her sexuality.
Reese said you never just
grab someone and kiss them
whether you’re two women, two
men, a man and a woman,
and that’s when we did this
Sort of choreography where I
said well if I put my hand up
To your cheek and let you know
that I’m actually
reciprocating the kiss.
Then it will be something that’s
actually quite beautiful.
Each character is in their own
world of achievement
and ambition and trying to get
ahead, meanwhile
there’s this greater force of
nature about to shut
everything down and we’re not
paying any attention.
Daniel we’ve gotta get out of
Wuhan before 10,
they’re locking it down.
Creating Wuhan out of the
Anaheim train station
was insane, but it was
so beautifully done.
Wuhan has one train station
that had kind of an amazing hump
and then two smaller humps and
I thought oh my gosh
the new metro link station
In Anaheim has that same
sort of shape to it.
We were shooting the train
station really, really late
at night, and literally I think
the train had to go off duty.
So when the train was done
wherever it was, it came to us
and in 30 minutes, man,
he had put up everything and
changed the signs and
what looked like just a regular,
uh, American train
became a train to Wuhan.
(SPEAKING CHINESE)
He says we can’t
Uh, tell him who we are
Daniel sees COVID first hand
he's ringing the bell and no one
is listening.
And watching that
experience for him
in this moment in time,
It really feels to resonant
and so relevant
and is really tremendous.
♪♪